[Music]
elaine maxwell apparently
her lawyers are grasping at everything
and they're trying to get her case
thrown out
because the juror the jury selection or
whatever the jurors weren't diverse
enough yeah you know what that wasn't
diverse enough the [ __ ] that you were
feeding to epstein
how about throwing some old hoes in
there that'd be nice if they were
diverse in terms of
that's the beauty that's the beauty of
identity politics though
is that you can use it as a tool to just
get anything
removed or like as an attack on
something that you don't like yeah
i mean like this is what happened with
wall street bets yeah they started
calling them alt-right they had a
discord this is crazy
like basically they say the word [ __ ]
and like they call each other like
smooth brain and like all that kind of
stuff
yeah smooth yeah and they they have like
just like these insults to each other
like man i'm autistic blah blah and
that's like their culture
and so as a way to censor the discord
as they said oh it's hate speech we
pulled it off discord there's a specific
thing that they pulled off actually
they had some sort of like word
generator that was
in the discord so it would
it was something automated it wasn't
even what the people were saying
it was an automated thing that ended up
saying the n-word
so some bot it was a bot but it wasn't a
bot as in like i'm gonna be a fake
subscriber it was some sort of like
remember when you can like find your rap
name
and you type something in and then it
shoots out yeah it was something
it was super removed from people
actually saying things
it wasn't even that they're using the
word [ __ ] etc it was some sort of
automated
program spit out i guess the n-word or
another offensive word and based on that
they shut down the discord and then they
got it back up by the way and probably
because of elon said corporate whatever
got to discord as well
shame but that's just like that's just
politics
and then pull it off it's not only
identity politics dude that's like
i mean that's like classic like
silencing yeah
yeah right i mean that's what jimmy
kimmel was doing essentially i see his
little [ __ ]
corporate tap dance their russian the
russian
interference behind wall street bets is
like you are
[ __ ] tap dancing dude you were tap
dancing for corporate interest you
[ __ ]
phony yeah and then he jon stewart
supported jon stewart the [ __ ] goat
one of the most pure guys from
everything i've heard yeah he's tweeted
in support of wall street bets and then
uh kimmel was like at real donald trump
is that you [ __ ] you
yeah [ __ ] yeah it was trash someone
commented and took his blackface picture
sent it to him and goes jimmy kimmel is
this you
that's funny it's a shame that that's
when he was funniest yeah
it's hard but blackface jimmy was so
much funnier
yeah and he's such a [ __ ] s it's like
you don't have enough money jimmy
you don't have enough money dude to have
some [ __ ] integrity dude
yeah it's it's it it is mind-boggling
that you want to be invited to the party
that much
he hosts who wants to be a millionaire
that's so much money this guy he's also
working on that show yeah he hosts oh
he's just part of the system that's
more embarrassing than anything you know
what it is they got dirt on him
oh they have to they have to have some
epstein-s tape on him because there's no
way a guy who is
actually funny yeah that guy who was
actually a [ __ ] hilarious dude
the guy show stuff was fun guy show was
good cranky anchors was good
there's a bunch of these yeah so i'm
almost positive we should look up
but he was a funny [ __ ] and he was
actually really good if you listen to
like the earlier kimmel interviews and
stuff he was good
yeah he could carry an interview well
yeah and to see him become he was cranky
anchors right yeah him
and adam corolla yep and he to become a
complete corporate [ __ ] shill
i wonder if they're still cool because
corolla doing his own thing he's a wild
boy
he's out there i doubt that i doubt that
they start chasing the money man
don't you get enough but is it the money
or is it the acceptance from that peer
group of this is
what's happening you can't even go to
parties no more it's like the stupidest
thing to want to go to the party
who wants to be a millionaire you're
just chasing the check yeah the answer
is him right
i mean i don't know i i just don't know
i think it's
it's got to be more than money they got
to have something bad on him i bet you
the blackface thing is
is it for the iceberg yeah it's got to
be minimal
yeah it's got to be something so bad
that he's willing to look like a
complete sellout
knowing full well they're going to call
him a sellout
like knowing full well but now your
peers are going to go because he's going
out of his way
like if he's hosting the show and he
says the russian [ __ ] it's like okay
yeah someone put that in teleprompter
said tell him what to say but he's going
out on twitter like attacking jon
stewart for what and he's also
that's what makes me think even more hmm
that's what makes me think he
more he has to double down or he's got
that much of an ego where he was just
getting [ __ ] trashed on twitter
for saying the russiagate thing or well
he deleted the trump the steward comment
he deleted that yeah [ __ ] yeah absolute
[ __ ] man this guy it's
it's sad i know we're talking right now
to a lot of people that only know kimmel
as like the late version of kimmel
yeah and they're like what do you mean
he's funny like their
mind is blown that we could be defending
this guy but there was a time where he
was an
actually funny guy and it's such a
[ __ ] shame to see someone go from
like
real talent and hilarity to corporate
shill
just after they have money i don't even
mind if you're broke and you do it to
get paid
yeah you know what i'm saying if one of
my friends has nothing goes for it
okay fine but to be paid to be a
multi-millionaire
he's can you look up his net worth sorry
please don't it's going to piss me off
even more but no no no
no but to prove the point he's got to be
worth tens of millions yeah i even
understand to a degree
doing it to keep your abc show on the
air initially because you don't want to
feel like a failure on the biggest stage
yeah 15 million or no 50 million dollar
net worth
it's too much i don't know if that you
don't need it you don't need it
anyway anyway actually gonna be gone you
started a comedy club
shout out to rihanna she did more for
indians than gandhi
oh yeah she talked about them farmers
bro bro oh okay
rihanna bro r.i.p to her mentions
because shits are going to be nuts
but low-key you need to keep that hair
coming in yeah
yeah yo you're right yo hey honest weave
ain't coming from rihanna okay she got
to go to the source
yeah true she got to make sure them
farmers are doing what they got to do
growing
up throw that hair she's been the most
valuable crop in india
that's a cash crop yeah no but she's
west indies and so she's got to take
care of her actual indies you know what
i mean
that's true r.i.p to screech that's true
r.i.p is screech bro yeah r.i.p is
screech
he's kind of a legend yeah hey he
probably better off yeah i mean
screech's been dead downhill bro
downhill hey game stop yeah